[Music]
foreign
a member of the K-Pop group Astro has
died he was 25 years old
[Music]
Astros label confirmed the sad news in a
statement on Wednesday asking fans to
respect the family's privacy sharing
that both family members Astro members
and staff were deeply saddened adding
that the musician's funeral will be
private per his family's wishes
[Music]
had been a member of the K-Pop group
since 2016. he also gained notoriety as
part of the group's first official
subunit moonbin and sanha which included
moonbin and fellow member Yoon sanha
[Music]
the duo dropped their first EP in out in
2020 followed by refuge in 2022 and
incense in January they kicked off their
first tour in Seoul on March 18th and
19th and had five more shows left on the
schedule the same day his death was
announced moonbin and Saha were
announced as part of the lineup for the
upcoming 29th dream concert set to take
place on May 27th
[Music]
foreign